And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's and welcome to our modules, the Stop Fighting Cancer
series.
This course is going to be, we created it really to help people that may never be able
to come to our clinic or maybe don't need to come to our clinic.
They just need a little extra hand holding, a little extra guidance.
It's meant to try to break down my book into pieces that are maybe more usable.
It's a long book.
I know there's a lot of information.
And sometimes when you get a grave diagnosis like cancer, it seems to like you're drinking
from a fire hose.
Sometimes it's hard to get that information and really distill it down to what you need.
So we tried to simplify it through these modules.
We're going to have some different protocols that you can use as you can, they'll help guide
you through your process a little bit better.
So a little bit about me, why I got into cancer.
It was never my desire.
So I got into cancer because I really was led into cancer.
This is really my calling.
I was really graduated as a chiropractor and really as a functional doctor, functional medical
doctor kind of thing at that time though we didn't use that terminology.
But the process that God took me through, I was always intrigued with the right even
while I was in school, the right machine, the technology that we use primarily for cancer
patients.
And I was always big into nutrition dietary things since actually since I was younger.
My mom really have to give her the credit for leading us and our family down that way before
it was even cool.
She was into nutrition and diet and eating well.
So, but while I was in school, I got intrigued with this right machine, a royal right.
And I don't, I know why now, but I didn't know why then when I graduated, I was out of
some day I want to have a right machine.
And it wasn't until years later in the 90s, I graduated in the 80s, in the 90s, one of
my patients came to me and she had breast cancer in both breasts and they gave her three
months to live if she didn't do chemo and radiation and she refused it for her personal reasons.
And that was like my aha moment, time to buy this right machine that I had been looking
at.
And she lived another 13 years with the use of the right, with use of nutrition, with what
I do at that time.
Slowly God sent me another patient, another cancer patient, another cancer patient and I
started to really see what his calling was for me is to help cancer patients.
And even in my own journey, you could read about my personal journey with cancer as well
on our website where I had some very dark days where I didn't know if I was going to make
it.
And I'm not guaranteed tomorrow.
So maybe you're watching this video and I'm not even here anymore.
But God is with us through all these things.
I really believe that and I believe he has a purpose.
And in our gravest consequences that we're dealing with in life, even in your cancer,
he has a purpose and it's to bring him glory and ultimately to glorify you through it in
the end.
So I trust him in that.
I know that he's led me down this pathway that I feel like it's our real as a clinic.
It's our responsibility to give as much information as we possibly can to help people.
We want to help you and I want these modules to be a blessing to you.
Please come back to this site over and over again.
I'm going to be constantly adding more information.
We're going to be adding different protocols.
We're going to be adding different tools that you could use.
So as you get through these seven modules, it's only going to take you a couple of hours.
But come back.
We're going to be adding more and more stuff that's going to be a benefit to you.
You have access to it.
So utilize these services.
So as God gives me information and puts something on my heart to share with you, I'm going to
make a video.
I'm going to put it in writing.
We're going to put it together.
Please also download all my books.
There are all a free download.
Utilize those.
We just want you to feel like you're being serviced and you're being cared for and that
you're being loved and you're certainly being prayed for.
So that's the most important thing.
So I hope this is a blessing to you and we'll see you at the end of these modules and throughout
this whole time.
It's throughout your whole journey.
Thanks so much.
Bye bye.